hello everyone and welcome back with the
second game of the match
versus uh pragnanda uh you guys uh said
that the first one was incredible and i
thought okay there's no way the second
one will be just uh uh you know it is
awesome to watch but again i was wrong
so let's dive straight into it now
alireza has the white pieces and he's
down by a point in the match he will of
course try to uh try to bounce back let
me just uh fix the board a little bit
you guys said that it was a bit too
large so let me just uh okay so i i
think this will do just nicely uh so
let's dive straight into it uh
there's quite a lot to enjoy in this one
as well so now alireza needs to bounce
back he opens with e4 and frog goes for
the very fighting sicilian defense he
plays pawn to c5 we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and now not the open
sicilian with d4 alireza goes for bishop
to b5 didn't medina
attack uh we have g6 and now bishop
captures and c6 we have b captures
castles by alireza and now just a bishop
to g7 by prague we rook to e1 and queen
to c7 this is a setup
that is a favorite of many a player for
example magnus crossing plays this
daniel dubo plays this even abdul
sartrov plays this um uh
so uh you know a very very strong people
play this uh we have d3 and now pawn to
e5 we have pawn to c3 uh preparing to
strike in the center with the d4 knight
to f6 and now pawn to d4 right away
characters characters and now e captures
on the four queen captures boldly
putting the queen in front of the bishop
but luckily for all there is that there
are no good discoveries with the knight
to be made so here castles by prague and
now comes knight to c3 uh there is a
game uh and it's a very very interesting
it's hard to say valeresa knows this or
maybe he just uh i'm pretty sure alireza
knows this but there is a game uh prague
already played against jobava uh also
with the black pieces where e5 was
played it was played this year in prague
so it's a fairly new game i'm sure
alireza knows this and he improves with
knight the c3 uh which is um interesting
as e5 the move job played against prague
is the second move recommended by the
engine and now it is knight to c3 which
is the first move recommended by the
engine so
uh he definitely knows what he's doing
here and it is now as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how prague meets this very very strong
or rather the strongest idea he plays
queen to b6 just offers a queen trade uh
as uh his queen and c7 is strong but
alireza's queen on d4 is just much more
powerful just a completely centralized
queen so of course you want to do
something about this and there is a game
uh where if i was played uh that's i i
messed up i thought it was a completely
new game uh when i uh mentioned the job
versus program but there is a game
actually between darius and alexander
linderman that was played last year
where uh e5 was played but here we have
queen captures on b6 and it is now in
fact as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how the
game uh continues in a completely new
territory a captures on b6 and now frog
improves his pawn structure has a very
nice uh pawn mass here
on the on on the queen side and now e5
violet is challenging the knight knights
the e8 and the bishop to e3 not putting
pressure on the b6 pawn but uh prague
just goes uh rook to a6 he says i'm
defending the pawn this way you don't
have a light square bishop so my rook is
perfectly safe on a6 even though for the
moment it's a bit inactive so rook a to
d1 and now we have pawn to f6 with this
pawn on e5 this knight is just looking
very silly here so of course prague
wants to eliminate it with bishop to f4
uh if captures an e5 with bishop
captures on e5 and now pawn to d5
advancing the pawn all the way freeing
up the light square bishop and now uh
the the pawns are doing a a good job
just you know uh he uh further uh
advancing especially the d-pawn which is
a pass pawn so bishop captures and g7
not king capture sorry i probably
actually cap a capture with the knight
knight to e5 now attacking the c6 pawn
and bishop to b7
uh pregnant defends it this way with a3
and now knight to f5 we have pawn to h3
uh and now pawn to d4 prague starts
advancing his past pawn knight to e4 and
now pawn to c5 so the pawn chain keeps
improving and advancing knight to g5 now
and here we have bishop the c8 taking
care of this e6 square you don't want to
allow something like knight to e6 we
have rook to c1 alersa prepares b4 this
will allow the rook to maybe infiltrate
the position
and now rook to a7 biologist we have
pawn to b4 definitely the strongest move
in this and many other positions and now
rook captures on a3 grabbing the pawn
here b captures on a on c5 and now first
d3 it's very important to throw in this
move you are threatening d2 which would
win the game so rook c to d1 by alireza
and not b captures on c5 if you could
get
this pawn all the way to c3 and have
them both protected of course it would
be a winning game so already has to go
upon grabbing knight captures and d3
even though you do prefer your knight so
close to the black king c for now
advancing the past c pawn knights the e5
and pawn to c3 we have rook to d5
algorithm wants to put his rook behind
the pass pawn which is what you should
always do whether you are escorting the
pawn or trying to prevent the pawn from
being escorted
pawn to c2 and now rook to c5 uh keeping
an eye on that c1 square not allowing uh
uh proc spawn the queen knight to d4 now
defending the pawn and here we have rook
to c7 and this is what the title of the
video really uh is all about uh this is
where alireza tries to perform the
devilish trick but only if prague falls
for it uh and indeed the position is
better for products some would even say
much better but you have to find the
absolute best way to play and prague
missed it in the game the the absolute
best way to play is rook to b3 with the
idea of rook to b1 and even with best
defense from alareza let's say knight to
f3 rook to b1 now uh there really is no
good move for
uh for white uh you you have to play
rook captures on c2 and this is the only
way for you to survive you have to give
up the exchange rook captures through
capture sunny one knight captures an e1
knight captures on c2 now knight
captures and you get this position where
okay all it is is upon uh but prague
will be up the exchange so this is the
absolute best way to play it but uh uh
bishop to a6 is what uh prague played in
the game going for that knight the e to
check
it's looking like it wins on the spot
because it delivers check it threatens
pawn to c1 so it seems like you're
winning the exchange out of the way but
there is a move that he missed so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the move that
pretty much immediately wins the game
for already
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh you know
following the advice and quote of david
bronstein and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
knight to g4 this is what alireza played
and now there is no defense uh point is
that if prague continues with his idea
of knight to e2 check then we just play
king h2 and now if c1 queen we ignore
the queen and we deliver checkmate
knight h6 check king to h8 only move and
of course rook captures on h7 is
checkmate this is what progress when he
played bishop to a6 uh but um uh you
know this is rapid of course such things
will happen he was below the one minute
mark and well yeah
it just didn't go his way in this one
bishop to a6 so knight to g4
in the game and now as we saw that this
doesn't work uh prague of course started
defending with knight to f5 we have rook
captures on c2 now comes rook to b3 uh
prague had to give back give away his
surprise pass c pawn rook to b3 now rook
to c6 going after the bishop here bishop
to b5 now knight to f6 with check and
there just isn't a good way to defend
this position uh king the h8 was played
now comes knight captures on h7 uh
offering a rook for the rook and f8 and
there really isn't anything better so
bishop captures rook captures on f8 king
to g7 attacking the bishop now knight f
to e6 with check we have king to h6 now
knight f7 check as all of these squares
are now covered there really
isn't all that much you can do king back
to h7 now comes knight to the e5 and he
was in this position on mu 42 that uh
pregnant resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here he is down
to pawns and there is no
way to recover from this also it's very
easy to win this the bishop is hanging
once the bishop moves doesn't really
matter where you're going to threaten to
infiltrate the position with with the
rook and if you stop this we just pick
up the pawn for example knight to f8
with chuck king g7 we're going to pick
up this pawn as well
or capture with this knight and there i
mean you're down three pawns of course
completely winning for alireza who was
up on time really really a lot like i
said prague was down below uh below the
one minute mark how it is i had like
four maybe five minutes i can even check
i don't want to like mislead you guys or
anything uh uh you know i wouldn't do
that uh but yeah there is a no alert had
two two and a half minutes uh and prague
had 18 seconds on the clock so it makes
sense to resign here uh so yeah that's
the game i hope you guys enjoyed it uh
there already bounces back and the match
is still on we'll we'll see what happens
two more games to go yeah and uh we'll
see who will take the the first match uh
so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by all it is
a bouncing back like this i would like
to thank nagarjuna
peter rodriguez alex barcelia francis
enrique yemeni for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup uh until it finishes most
likely so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and uh uh just uh uh you know inform
you guys i have made the game between uh
chess master the grand master edition
uh and uh
and uh stockfish 14 powered by powered
by ai and it is quite in the game i will
probably upload it tomorrow before the
uh uh
rest of the ftx cryptocup starts so stay
tuned for that as well
see you soon